every year the academy awards celebrates
the lives of actors and directors who
have sadly passed away but in what has
become an unfortunate tradition some
notable celebrities don't make the cut
keep watching to hear about iconic
actors the oscars in memoriam segment
completely snubbed the in memoriam
segment of the 94th annual academy
awards ceremony was a sad look back on
the many talented people of hollywood
who have died within the last year as
always this year's segment featured a
long list of names including everyone
from directors like peter bogdanovich
and buddy van horn to actors like norman
lloyd and olympia dukakis while every
person in the montage got at least a
moment of remembrance the late sydney
poitier betty white and ivan reitman all
received extended mournful dedications
by notable stars who previously worked
with the deceased artists during the
segment tyler perry jamie lee curtis and
bill murray all appeared separately on
stage to remember their respective
friends however as with nearly every
year the academy also made a number of
notable omissions including two
comedians who both sadly passed away
within the last year of course while
most people on twitter were busy buzzing
about the will smith and chris rock
incident some fans were probably quite
unhappy with these particular exclusions
for reasons that are unclear the academy
left out two of the last year's most
notable deaths in the world of comedy
unfortunately neither full house star
bob saget nor snl star nor macdonald
were included in the in memoriam segment
despite the fact that the actors and
comedians both died within the last
seven months the academy does not appear
to have acknowledged their passing in
the awards ceremony mcdonald died at the
age of 61 on september 14 2021 nearly
nine years after being diagnosed with
leukemia despite the long amount of time
between mcdonald's diagnosis and passing
his death came as a shock to much of the
world the former weekend update anchor
chose not to share news of his health
publicly but did inform a few of his
closest friends notably this list of
friends included saget in the aftermath
of mcdonald's death saget recorded a
tearful 37-minute remembrance of his
longtime friend and shared it with his
followers on youtube
he was
one of the uh well he's one of the most
important people in my life and one of
the sweetest
sadly saggett also died only a few
months later on january 9th at the age
of 65 after suffering an accidental head
injury in a florida hotel upon his
passing many fans remembered saggett for
his roles as danny tanner on full house
and as old ted mosby on how i met your
mother this snub of both performers is
especially notable to fans not just
because of the stature of saggit and
mcdonald's work but also because each
performer made their own impact on the
world of film throughout their legendary
careers although both bob saget and norm
mcdonald were best known for their work
on tv and the stage they do have film
credits to their name mcdonald was a
regular of adam sandler movies beginning
with the classic 1995 comedy billy
madison from there he went on to appear
in grownups jack and jill and the
ridiculous six zagat's own film career
included small roles in movies like half
baked and dumb and dumber when harry met
lloyd however his most enduring film
legacy may just be his work as a
director in addition to several
documentaries and tv movies saggett
helmed the spoof film farce of the
penguins and the indie comedy benjamin
did everything go wrong for me it was
when your wife left you
yeah oh yeah yeah
saggett also directed mcdonald several
times throughout both performers careers
in the world of film mcdonald's starred
in sagitt's 1998 dark comedy dirty work
about two down on their luck brothers
who raise money for their father's heart
surgery by performing unscrupulous acts
of revenge for paying clients while it's
not necessarily the type of movie that
is typically recognized at the oscars
the fact that both performers did work
in film makes it even tougher for fans
to get over saget and mcdonald's
exclusion from the in memoriam segment
the absence of some notable dearly
departed celebrities in the in memoriam
segment is an oscar's tradition about as
common as stunning gowns and surprise
upsets and this year it was
unfortunately bob saget and norm
macdonald who missed the cut check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the
academy awards are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]